i've been fortunate enough to be at the
institute for
13 odd years now
and when i first started
um
one person would pretty much do the
whole pipeline themselves
and we used to do things in single glass
tubes and grow things one at a time and
use a single channel for pets to do the
operation
and
i think it was probably about the time
of the human genome project coming to
the fore and the acceleration that
happened with that
which basically scaled everything up
quite drastically
so as a group leader i suddenly employed
20 people
to work in my team
we were still doing things quite
manually then but on a larger scale in
96 well format
and then as technologies move forwards
we've moved from 96 to 384 well format
and instead of doing things manually we
now have robotics to do a lot of the
liquid transfers which we used to do by
hand
so things have changed pretty
pretty drastically over the years